i still like accepting random challenges
makes you less nervous sort of you don't
need to
don't need to choose you also don't need
to explain
very comfortable c4 e6 okay let's play
h4 maybe
b should be seven okay now we go knight
c3
c5 so what's the point of h4
maybe there is no point okay let's take
on d5
and play bishop g5 maybe
okay now it kind of makes some little
sense
not that much so
[Music]
yeah let's say bcp2
h6 and then we take
probably take on c5 simply
and something like rook c1
but this guy seems to be quite strong i
would say
he's playing natural moves and he's
playing them quickly
which is which is very impressive
um
yeah i don't know what to do here like
94 but it's a bit
i mean a bit too dry to play for win so
maybe we start with queen a4 followed by
rook d1
also e4 is technically in there
[Music]
he allows an ending which is
probably quite a good scenario for white
but it's still not much of course
bishop takes c3 is not a threat yet
right i can play this
uh maybe it is just right here okay it
doesn't matter anymore
can i sacrifice a pawn with knight d4
i probably can
so the point after bishop takes h4 is
something like
okay it doesn't happen anyway
but now i start to like our position
actually so we go a3 first
to change the ninth and we take a six
play um
[Music]
you know b sub g4 or maybe g3 first okay
let's play g3
or maybe knight a4 yeah let's try knight
e4
like there is not much going on and if
we try to play for the wins and at least
we should not protect this h4 pawn
[Music]
i mean we should not protect it yet yeah
i mean if you will spend time
in such a dry position for uh
[Music]
for protect uh protecting the pawns and
it will be very difficult to
[Music]
to sort of play for the wii knight four
is at least ambitious
we want it c5
which kind of
kind of makes him
makes him nervous i believe
so knight c5 what do we want bishop
takes b2
rook b1 then we take
okay looks interesting to me
also once again it's not that white is
better otherwise
so why not try it yeah he simply plays
uh
[Music]
plays like this so can we play knight b7
rook d7 and then some
[Music]
some brilliant trick like rook c2
okay let's play this first
at very least we have bishop a6
maybe bishop a6 is just a very good move
by the way
yeah so bishop a6
like if he takes on b2 then we will will
win the rook in the end
if he plays rock c to c7 then i guess we
have bishop b5
he probably has knight d4 there
[Music]
some 96 check i don't know
i also like rook c2
[Music]
so what happens after rook c2
after rook city he has knight is seven
at first yeah so we should probably
probably try bishop a6
so if he takes on b2 we'll probably
survive this yeah we go rook c2 or
something yeah so he plays
he plays this now b should be five
is 94 that obvious for everybody i mean
i thought i'm
[Music]
sort of cool to to find it
i mean otherwise i think white is in
great shape
maybe not actually
maybe you can just take on b7s and take
on b2
play like this
yeah i'm not such a big fan of our
position anymore i must say
but yeah white is probably pressing
in all the lines without 94. so 94 what
do we
yeah he plays it so what do we have here
so we have 96
check let's say king is 7
[Music]
we can take on c7 and play 98
then knight xb5 is there
[Music]
i mean of course we can just play d but
then he takes on c1
takes on b7 and it's very very dry
yeah i don't see it i must say
okay let's play 96
then after k7 i mean i'll probably just
take
so rook takes c1 i'll go knight f5 check
maybe
[Music]
try to play this position
i mean i think it is a bit better for
white but
it's obviously far from being a real
attempt
bishop bishop a6 bishop c it was
probably there but i missed it okay
yeah well this is like slightly
i know h4 is hanging here so it's not
slightly better
h5 maybe
now he has king e6 yeah i spoiled it
spelled it it seems
should i be trying to win this pawn down
maybe not him
why not
okay this is a blunder
[Music]
yeah this was a sharp game this 94
is a nice tactics here i mean i
mentioned it in in the very end but
does it i mean in the very beginning but
doesn't really work
bishop a6 rook c7 bishop b5
knight d4 let me look at it again
so what what can we play here
ed rook c1 doesn't seem to work
okay 96 check looks logical
king is seven so now i could uh
i mean maybe i should have played it xd4
and after rook takes c1 simply rook
takes c1 rook d6 rook c7 but i thought
it shouldn't be
really better like king f8 and then you
take on d4 it's not much
otherwise knight c7 runs into rook takes
c7 followed by knight takes b5
yeah maybe 96 check is a mistake or
maybe there is not uh yeah i mean i have
a strange
um
strange mindset that white should be
better here but actually why exactly i
mean i don't know
a knight on b7 it's not that you're
always better with the knight on b7
yeah maybe we take on c7 and knight
eight once again but then i thought it's
knight xb5
yeah i guess it is it is correct
yeah maybe white is not better at all
maybe this line was
sort of reasonable then after rook b7 of
course i had to play uh
bishop a6 and then bishop c
followed by uh bishop takes c5 then
white is a bit better i would say
but it's quite obvious that it's still
i mean it's still within uh this draw
margin
all right